Fulton County Judge Scott McAfee has
just announced that every minute of
President Donald Trump's trial in the
election interference case will be
broadcast for the public this would seem
highly unusual as cameras and recording
equipment are almost never permitted in
federal court
but this is not a federal court and more
important this is a show trial
Trump is not seriously being indicted
for committing any crimes be it in New
York or DC or Florida or Georgia or
wherever else they try to legally Lynch
him next he is being arrested and
imprisoned potentially for over 700
years because he's the leader of an
actual political opposition
political opposition in America is
frequently play acted it's not real
candidates run against each other
sometimes they even differ on some
matters of policy but on the big
controversial questions that you're not
allowed to bring up Mass migration
globalization liberalization War those
kinds of things and those issues both
parties in recent decades have tended to
deliver the same results no matter who
wins until Trump
Trump who upended Republican Orthodoxy
on all of those things so now they're
going to get him
and they'll make up some crimes to
justify it along the way but most
importantly
they're going to make sure that we watch
it
because this is not an ordinary
prosecution it's a legal and political
revolution a total upending of our
established traditional political order
and the revolution will be live streamed
I'm Michael knowlesis the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show The White House
wants to take away your beer they want
you to only have two beers per week
we'll get to that in just that really
important news story in just one second
first one first though
while Donald Trump is having his show
trial broadcast for the whole world on a
bazillion indictments for seven million
years in prison
the White House
is asserting executive privilege to
cover up the crimes of Joe Biden
so Joe Biden would appear to have
committed actual political corruption
there is an investigation into that now
Biden denied that he ever engaged in any
of the corruption with Hunter Biden as
the front man for the Enterprise and
with the Crooked foreign adversaries and
even allies who
Hunter encountered to sell Joe's
influence when he was vice president of
the United States the White House is
saying no not going to happen
so what's been what's been the timeline
here
Joe denies any knowledge of this it
comes out that he knew about it Joe
denies any involvement it comes out he
was very involved in the business on a
whole lot of phone calls invited
Hunter's business partner over to the
White House for lunch that sort of thing
then
Joe Biden says well I've had no
correspondence with my son about
business which is sort of true in the
sense that Joe Biden conducted business
with his son under a pseudonym while he
was vice president in fact under
multiple pseudonyms while he was vice
president so if a conservative were to
file a Freedom of Information Act
request for all of the emails of Joe
Biden pertaining to Rosemont Seneca the
front group the the the fake company
through which Hunter was conducting this
business no records would turn up
that's because Joe Biden was using a
pseudonym so now a conservative group
America First legal files a foia request
for all the pseudonyms that Joe Biden
used to conduct the business with Hunter
and the National Archive says no
in the National Archives is able to say
no to this foia request because
Joe Biden is asserting executive
privilege and this is this is a big
victory it seems like a failure because
we don't get those records this is a big
victory
foia
Freedom of Information Act can prove
guilt even when we don't get the
documents because the very fact that the
White House is exerting executive
privilege here proves
that these pseudonymous emails involved
the president
if if these uh these pseudonyms
Robin Ware
Robert L Peters all of these Joe Biden
pseudonyms if they were not actually the
pseudonyms of Joe Biden the White House
would have no standing to to exert
assert executive privilege but because
they obviously do hear we know Joe Biden
was doing all of this stuff
and yet they are going to throw up a
roadblock after roadblock for the
investigation of actual crime we're
talking about actual high-level
political corruption selling American
influence to the highest bidder raking
in millions and millions of dollars at
least from around the world meanwhile
Donald Trump as president
called an elected representative in
Georgia and said hey Georgia elected
officials uh I think that the election
was kind of corrupt can you look into
that for me and for that they're going
to try to throw him in the Clank they've
arrested his lawyers they've arrested
activists for him and they're going to
live stream the show trial
speaking of live streaming
this is the saddest story in our
politics right now forget about Biden
forget about Trump forget about war
forget about disease forget about
did you know that the late night TV
hosts have been out of work for well
over three months now
probably you didn't if you did it's
because I mentioned it once a couple of
weeks ago which was the first time that
I realized it because there's a writer's
strike in Hollywood so the wgas on
strike which means the writers for the
late night shows are on strike which
means the shows are in reruns and nobody
noticed it because very very few people
watch these shows anymore so in order to
fight back against this and try to make
some money for the staff of these shows
all of the big late night hosts Stephen
Colbert Jimmy Kimmel Jimmy Fallon Seth
Meyers all of these guys
are doing what what all white men in
America
or obliged to do
which is start a podcast here's their
podcast
one more time Jimmy yeah hi I'm Jimmy
Fallon I'm Stephen Colbert I'm Jimmy
Kimmel I thought when you said Jimmy you
meant me Jimmy but you meant Jimmy Jimmy
I always mean you but when you always be
admires who do you mean I mean John
Oliver makes the five of us together for
maybe an hour a day Strike Force Five is
the name of our podcast subscribe to it
now
Spotify or wherever else you get your
podcasts but Spotify you
oh my fight my face is never going to
lose this permanent state of cringe
do you get it I was talking to the one
Jimmy not the other Jimmy and then and
then they all try to get their little
line in there and then John Oliver who I
forgot was even in the podcast he just
does the John Oliver routine which is he
says something not funny but then he
says the f word afterward so that's
supposed to pass for comedy and
this was a revelation to me
and it's a revelation because when I was
a kid
Johnny Carson Jay Leno David Letterman
these were huge Stars these guys hosted
the the initially it was just one late
night show then it was you know two then
three then four late night shows but
still these were huge huge shows that
commanded a huge audience and now all of
these guys the hosts of the supposed big
late night shows these are franchises
that go back decades in network
television they have the same job that I
do we have the exact same job now
we just have podcasts
and this isn't merely a way to get
around the writer's strike and remain
relevant and stay in the news and maybe
make some money for the staff
this is true even when they're on TV
this is why no one noticed that they
were off air
because they're audiences which used to
be gigantic have dwindled down to very
very little Johnny Carson on his last
week on air
averaged 19 million viewers per show
his final show Johnny Carson's final
show
had 50 million viewers
and by the way this was in 1992 the U.S
population in 1992 was just north of 250
million people today it's something like
330 million people so the equivalent
today to 50 million viewers the last the
last night of the Johnny Carson show
would be equivalent to
65-ish million viewers today
what are these guys getting these guys
are pulling in
a million people a night
maybe maybe a little more sometimes
significantly less than that half a
million people a night for Seth Meyers I
think
that's a podcast
the major Network late night shows have
become
a podcast and so
any continued Allure of the
establishment media is a virtual
potemkin Village the culture has just
divided up there's no there's no one
thing that commands all of the eyeballs
probably until the Trump show trial that
will probably be the highest ratings of
any television program in decades but
that's all divided up and and this is
important for a political order because
the ruling class was able to exert a lot
of soft power when everyone was tuned in
certainly to the three network
television stations and then even with
cable people were still watching a lot
of the same kind of stuff so you can
exert a lot of soft power through
propaganda and conditioning but when
that totally breaks up and everyone's
just listening to their own podcasts
which get what a million views or even
half a million views some podcasts get
very fewer and still have a devoted
following well then the political orders
got to get a little tougher if they
can't exert that soft power and people
are starting to ask questions and people
are starting to question things and
people are starting to think for
themselves then the enforcement
mechanism of the state is going to get a
lot tougher and it's going to start
cracking down on dissidents it's going
to start arresting people who question
the ruling class as we are seeing every
single single day that is the
consequence of a breakdown of the common
culture maybe it's a good thing because
we're not always hypnotized as we used
to be but now the the bare reality of
our political order and the coercion
that it entails is is becoming much
clearer and we've got to talk about that
when you want to talk to your friends
you got to check out your talk right now
go to puretalk.com Knowles is your cell
phone in desperate need of a replacement
you know the signs your battery life is
so short that you gotta have a charger
on hand all the time cracked screen that
gives you glass splinters it's time to
put that old phone to rest and upgrade
to a new 5G Samsung Galaxy from Pure
Talk for free get a free 5G Samsung
Galaxy with two day battery life edge to
edge display and Ultra strong Gorilla
Glass when you sign up for Pure talks
unlimited talk text and 15 gig data plan
for just 35 bucks a month plus it comes
with a mobile hotspot you are not using
pure talk you are simply paying too much
that's the rule okay get all the data
that you could ever need for half the
price of the big carriers on America's
Most Dependable 5G network not a
similarly Dependable Network the most
Dependable 5G Network go to
puretalk.comwels for your free super
durable 5G Samsung Galaxy when you
switch to Pure Talk
puretalk.com Knowles make the switch to
my cell phone company that I use Pure
Talk the official Wireless partner of
the daily wire
also when you're hanging out with your
friends
you've got to play the game
the most popular game in the entire
world according to the Michael Knowles
Institute of of card games yes or no it
is spicy controversial some might say
conspiratorial the yes or no game is all
that and so much more now the
anticipated follow-up to that
best-selling game is finally here yes or
no conspiracy expansion pack it's
available at dailywire.com shop with
over 110 new cards the conspiracy
expansion pack is a comprehensive
compendium of conspiracy
tackle topics such as political
assassinations Cryptids chemicals in our
food and more you can discover more
about your family and friends than ever
before and judge their stances on the
most hotly contested conspiracies in
American life if you haven't gotten the
full yes or no game head on over right
now daily wire.com shop pick it up then
get the all-new yes or no conspiracy
expansion pack because the original game
wasn't controversial enough I would
order this now we've sold out of this
game
three or four times at this point it
always sells out pretty quickly so if
you are going to want it looking ahead
if you're gonna want it for Thanksgiving
if you're going to want it for Christmas
I would just get it now I don't know the
next time they'll come in hopefully
we'll restock them soon but order it now
that you have the chance
speaking of live streaming and the
Judiciary
this is the most pathetic story
of the week a federal judge has just
ruled
that age limits on porn on online porn
or unconstitutional
so some of us conservatives have said
just ban porn it's not good it's really
bad it leads to the exploitation of
women it leads to addiction especially
for young men it's in no way good for
anybody it's just it's like a it's like
any drug we should just discourage it
and ban it ideally
but the the softer more conciliatory
Middle Ground approach is well hey let's
at least make sure that little kids
aren't looking important we know that
the the median age of exposure to porn
these days is something like 10 or 11
years old maybe younger now so let's
just you got to prove that you're at
least 18. just like you used to go buy a
Playboy down the street at the at the
magazine stand you had to show an ID to
do that well let's do that with far more
egregious online pornography and a
federal judge said no
no you can't make sure that
five-year-olds aren't looking at porn no
that's unconstitutional that's a
violation of the First Amendment this
weirdo judge man
Judge David a Ezra senior U.S District
Judge of the U.S District Court for the
Western District of Texas finds quote
the court finds that HB 1181 is
unconstitutional on its face that's the
law saying we're going to have some age
limits on porn
uh prohibited Texas from any further
enforcement of this law pending further
order or final judgment they say the
statute is not narrowly tailored and
chills the speech of plaintiffs in
adults who wish to access sexual
materials the law is not narrowly
tailored because it substantially
regulates protected speech is severely
under inclusive and uses overly
restrictive enforcement methods
okay
I don't know who needs to hear this I
guess this federal judge needs to hear
this I'll I'll pull myself closer to the
microphone here
pornography is not protected speech
it's not
in the last 50 years we've pretended
that it's protected speech
in America because of some stupid
Supreme Court rulings but it's not
it's smut our founding fathers the Great
Men Who Built our country the wise
Statesman through all of Western
Civilization have never considered
pornography to be protected speech it's
obscenity it's smut it appeals to the
prurient interest it has no artistic
Merit it has no no speech quality it's
it's like think of it this way
when an animal grunts
is that the same thing as when a human
being gives an oration
is The Barking of a dog the same as the
Pericles funeral oration no
they're both sounds but they're not both
speech
when we have an argument when we write a
letter when we give a speech that is
speech there's there's meaning to it it
appeals to reason it allows us to
deliberate and think about things in an
abstract way
when a when a dog grunts even when a
baby screams for milk that's not really
speech that's an expression of the of
the Instinct of the appetite it can be
an important type of communication it
can it can have an effect in the real
world but it's not the same thing as
speech what's the same thing here
when I
watch a movie if I watch Citizen Kane
that is speech
if if the court were to come in and say
you you can't have Citizen Kane
because we the judges don't like the
movie that would be a curtailment of
speech
Citizen Kane and some hardcore porn on
the internet are not the same thing one
is appealing to the intellect one is
appealing to the soul stirring the soul
and calling up sentiment that is
ultimately does have a reasonable
component to it pornography just excites
your lusts it's extremely unreasonable
it's the opposite of speech where did we
get this from we got this from Miller
versus California which is this 1973
Supreme Court decision there's so many
stupid decisions around this time we had
Roe v Wade obviously you had all of the
weird sex cases and you got this one too
Miller V California which modified the
definition of obscenity from that of
quote utterly without socially redeeming
value to that which lacks serious
literary artistic political or
scientific value so this is a weakening
of obscenity and therefore a weakening
of the government's ability to enforce
obscenity laws then in 97 we got the to
my mind the most egregious pro-porn
decision yeah that was in the name of
Free Speech but it was total BS and in a
way it's kind of undermined free speech
the Supreme Court rules in Reno versus
ACLU that the anti-indecency provisions
of the communications decency act were
unconstitutional so we talk about the
communications decency act that that
often comes up as a way to regulate big
Tech because you hear about section 230
which gives big Tech platforms certain
legal protections that have kind of
screwed us over in the long run because
it's allowed big Tech to censor
conservatives while receiving the
protections of a online platform rather
than a publisher but the communications
decency Act is really about decency and
Communications and it was a law intended
to address the new technological and
social issue of online pornography there
was a similar law passed around this
time called the child online protection
act and Republicans wanted to pass it
Democrats wanted to pass it even Bill
Clinton who was you know a little bit
loose in that Arena of sexual propriety
he signed it into law and yet this
ridiculous Court says no you can't have
anti-indecency provisions because that
would be a curtailment of free speech
porn is not free speech and this is a
reminder conservatives are never going
to win by trying to split hairs and find
some conciliatory middle ground with
something as egregious as hardcore
online porn a ubiquitous social problem
causing all sorts of of psychological
and spiritual and health issues among
American people
just ban it just go out there and be
bold and ban it and appoint bold judges
and don't do this to totally Shred the
Constitution or anything like that what
the Liberals say no do that to return us
to a time when we had a far more
reasonable
principle of constitutional
interpretation and statutory
interpretation
before the 1970s do you think things
were more reasonable or less reasonable
did the 1970s make things were better
and better behaved and more conducive to
flourishing I don't think so 70s was the
decade of disco and weird sex stuff and
cocaine okay and things have only gotten
crazier since so let's be bold guys
forget about this well we're gonna just
make sure that only 18 year olds can
look at poor not 17 year olds and I just
get rid of it it's bad it has no no
socially redeeming value what so ever
now speaking of speech
shift gear is hard here
some people are voicing their opinion
using their speech to say who they want
to be
the Republican nominee for president in
2024 and you know all of the polls
pretty much all of them without
exception have been overwhelmingly in
favor of Donald Trump but there's a new
poll out
that the people who don't want Trump to
be the nominee are touting as evidence
that maybe Donald will be upended as the
front runner here this is a poll from
The Young Republican National Committee
showing Donald Trump as the favorite
uh to be the GOP nominee
in 2024. now
I I hate to uh
Reign on this parade here for the people
who are supporting Governor DeSantis but
I don't think this poll shows exactly
what the anti-trump crowd thinks it
shows
now we we could talk about this over a
nice barbecue uh sometime if you invited
me over to your house but if you ever
did that you better make sure that
you've got propane that's why you got to
check out cinch right now go to
cinch.com use code Knowles have you ever
craved a nice barbecue meal with the
family say you go to the store get all
the groceries invite family over and
when you go to turn on the grill your
propane tank is empty well that's where
cinch comes in to save the day cinch is
a propane grill tank Home Delivery
Service they deliver propane grill tanks
right to your door since it delivers on
your schedule requires no long-term
commitment or subscription plus delivery
is completely contactless you don't have
to wait around at home track the order
on the Cinch app from anywhere whether
you're grilling steaks or lighting up
the patio heaters on a cold night
cinches propane delivery service ensures
that you have the fuel you need to make
the most of every moment go online to
cinch.com or download the Cinch app to
order new customers can get their first
tank exchange for just ten dollars with
promo code Knowles Canada wlas that is
cinch.com or download the Cinch app and
use promo code Knowles
k-n-o-w-l-e-sk get your first chance
use promo code nulls to get your first
tank exchange for just 10 bucks a
limited time offer you must live within
a cinched service area to redeem it
visit cinch.com offer four to tails
as you know the spooky season is quickly
approaching there will be demons out on
the prowl I guess there always are
because they're wandering about the
world seeking the Rune of souls but I'm
not just talking about woke corporations
that look upon your values with disdain
okay
let's unwoke Halloween
with Jeremy's chocolate our delicious
chocolates come in two forms he him with
nuts
and she her which is not less just as
our Lord intended don't be a ghoul head
on over to Jeremy's chocolate.com to
order your chocolates in time for
Halloween spooky
young Republican straw poll results are
in
top of the straw poll Ron DeSantis with
36.6 percent
he wins the straw poll
looks like good news for DeSantis Trump
comes in second very close second 35.4
percent
the bake third nine point one percent
Nikki seven and a half percent Tim Scott
five and a half percent
okay
this is in keeping with what I hear on
campus I travel to a lot of campuses I
give a lot of Campus speeches I talk to
a lot of young people especially the
sort of young people who would join the
college Republicans and who when they
get a little bit older would join the
young Republicans young Republicans are
more for young professionals and
I'll say who are you supporting in 2024
and the majority of them will say Ron
DeSantis
a minority of them will say Donald Trump
that's pretty much all I've been hearing
so this seems like good news for
DeSantis right it's a nice enough
headline it is not enough and the reason
it's not enough is because there are
multiple factions in the GOP
there is the
young Republican College Republican
Brooks Brothers wearing Country Club
belongings a little bit more
establishment leaning type of Republican
there are also the more eccentric
Republicans the populists and the
nationalists and the Paleo conservatives
and the traditionalists and all those
ists and isms I once heard it described
as uh the Obscure political monikers
being the right-wing version of gender
pronouns or just so many of them but
there are these disparate factions
okay and the fact is
Donald Trump has The Eccentric wing of
the party locked up the populists
they're not going for anybody but maybe
they'll flirt with Vivek but probably
they're with Trump the nationalists
mostly with Trump
the paleoconservatives pretty much with
Trump the all the eccentric Wing they're
with him
the group that Trump does worst with is
the more establishment Brooks Brothers
Country Club wing
the yrs the CRS the neoconservatives
that type
he does the worst with that
if Trump is only trailing the number one
spot among that group of conservatives
by by one and a half percentage points
or or less was it 1.2 percentage points
then his lead is dominant
any kid this is not just about Ron
DeSantis any candidate who wants to be
able to compete seriously against Trump
needs to be dominating among at least
one of the factions of the GOP think
about Reagan and Bush in 1980 Ronald
Reagan had the conservatives what we
might call the accentrists the populists
the nationalists the paleos that Reagan
had that part of the party social
conservatives George H.W bush had the
Brooks Brothers establishment
committee part of the party and Reagan
won and then they came together in a in
a Unity ticket that's that's why Reagan
picked bush
here Trump is statistically dead even
even Among The Establishment types
so
where does a competitor go from there
where does a competitor go
the DeSantis campaign is obviously
dealing with the the lackluster Poll
Grow or non-existent pole growth so now
the Never Back Down Super PAC
which is the DeSantis superback has
upended its strategy they've announced
that they're going to stop door knocking
in Nevada and California the reason for
this according to the spokesman is they
want to focus on the early primary
States so Aaron perine who's spokesman
for the Super PAC says we want to
reinvest in the first three
uh insinuating Iowa and New Hampshire
and South Carolina we see real
opportunities in the first three the
first three are going to set the
conditions for the March days now what's
weird about this is
Nevada is the second state as far as I
as far as I know
I don't think South Carolina is in the
first three I think Nevada is in the
first three so I don't know what lines
are getting crossed here or if this is
some spin because maybe they're not
doing as well in in Nevada either way
a turning away from Super Tuesday if you
launch your campaign you say we're going
to be in all these different states and
we're going to forget about the first
primary States we think we're already
going to do very well in Iowa and New
Hampshire and we're already looking
ahead to the super Tuesday States and
then you pull back from that that's not
a good sign I've worked on some
presidential campaigns where that's not
a good sign
I've seen it and we've seen it happen
for many years uh
so that I don't think DeSantis is out
yet
okay and I say I I know people are gonna
say I'm carrying water for Trump or
something here I'm really not I do like
Trump I like Trump very much he's the
best president in my lifetime I think he
reshaped the Republican party in a good
way I also really like Ron DeSantis and
my analysis would be absolutely the same
if I hated Donald Trump
or if I hated Rhonda santis my analysis
would be the same and I think the
analysis has been pretty close to
accurate and I think it's been proven
right at pretty much every step of the
way going back about six months now so
don't shoot the messenger guys if you're
upset that Donald Trump is leading then
you've got to change your campaign
strategy or or perhaps just recognize
that the conditions in this presidential
race we have not seen this kind of thing
since what 1892 where a conservative I'm
sorry where a president is running for a
non-consecutive second term maybe the
conditions are just such that
it's not the year to challenge somebody
that's that's the conclusion that Glenn
young can obviously has has reached in
Virginia
he's a he's a great looking presidential
candidate who just thinks he's not going
to be Trump and so he's he's staying on
the sidelines at least for now
but if
if you're pegging your hopes on well my
candidate is one point higher than the
guy who's 40 points ahead in the
National polls and he's one point higher
among the young Republican National
Committee
that ain't gonna cut it man and you're
gonna spin your wheels and spend a lot
of money on a strategy that is going to
continue not to work now there is there
is some not so terrible news for Ron
DeSantis there's something being
reported as awful news for Ron DeSantis
which is actually fake news and the
story is that a pro de Santa Super PAC a
50 million dollar Super PAC has shut
down and has flipped sides and is now
supporting Donald Trump and as far as I
can tell that's just completely made up
so this is from The Daily Mail exclusive
Ron DeSantis 50 million dollar Super PAC
closes doors after donors were spooked
by rookie mistakes
a strategist John Thomas secured 50
million dollars in donations for Ron to
the rescue the group will shut down
after donors had second thoughts and now
they're gonna they're going to support
Trump uh the the Super PAC appears to
have had basically no money on hand it
it secured promises for donations but it
never actually got the money and it just
seems like a like a scam there are a lot
of scam super Pacs out there because the
super Pacs are not allowed to have any
direct relation to the candidate so I
could today I could start the uh Doug
burgum for Doug burgum is the man give
us your money Super PAC I've never met
Doug burgum I have no intention of
giving Doug burgum any of my money and I
could go raise all of that money Donald
Trump had to deal with a lot of this
people raising money based on the the
positive feelings for Donald Trump and
then the Trump campaign never got not
got the money at all
so that seems to be what's happened here
uh but so that's a fake news story uh
but the the real news stories are bad
enough
okay and so I I've said it for months
now
I have no intention of endorsing in this
primary I like primaries I like when the
candidates duke it out so that they can
get tougher for the general election
Trump's a big boy he's got thick skin
the same thing goes for DeSantis the
same thing goes for Vivek and the other
guys too uh
uh even when you we talk about these
different parts of the party I'm a
fairly eccentric Republican who also
wears a lot of Brooks Brothers okay I
think I see
the different aspects of the party
relatively clearly and as of now
Trump's lead seems to me
solid totally totally solid
now speaking of stories that seem like
fake news in this case stories that are
not actually fake news the White House
wants to take away your beer they want
to limit you
to two beers per week
does President Biden want to limit
Americans to two beers a week
where is this coming from maybe I did
maybe I didn't miss you so much
all right well uh Dr George Coop who is
the director of the National Institute
of alcohol abuse and alcoholism says the
US May soon follow Canada and recommend
just two beers a week how do you guys
think that's gonna let me tell you what
I'm not gonna get involved in in uh in
that in that question right there I I
have no idea I've not seen the data I
cannot speak to this I will leave it to
the experts and not wait the experts say
two beers a week I will leave it to the
experts I'm just not going to comment on
that okay this is a great Exchange
not because of the beer thing who cares
no one's going to follow this advice but
because of what it tells you about the
experts
and what the conservatives think about
the experts and even what the Liberals
think about the experts
when Peter Ducey asks this question
green jump here gets a little smile she
goes oh here we go the beer question
yeah
Corrine Champ here knows this is
ridiculous
she knows that there's no win answering
this politically but she also knows that
two beers a week is ridiculous and it's
almost certainly a bogus study and no
one's going to pay attention to it
and but what does she say she says yeah
we um look I'll defer to The Experts all
right yeah okay listen to The Experts
in in a way she is
admitting the same thing about the
experts that the conservatives have now
long thought which is the experts are
often full of it
they're they conduct their studies the
studies often arrive at silly
conclusions and so we discard them oh
yeah well listen to The Experts Peter
tihi yeah whatever moving on
she's tacitly admitting that the experts
are often wrong
but
she won't go all the way
she she's tacitly admitting it's
ridiculous but she's also her
substantive answer is just listen to The
Experts
it's an amazing
very very subtle admission and response
and what it what it comes down to what
the upshot of all of it is I think is
that everybody knows the experts
frequently get it wrong the one thing I
know about science is that statistically
it's almost always wrong because
scientific discoveries and Innovations
end up getting upended sometimes
centuries later sometimes Generations
later sometimes Weeks Later
it's it's a tacit admission that our our
trust in science is misplaced but it's
it's also an admission that the
political ruling class will wield the
supposed credibility of science
willy-nilly as a way to skirt
responsibility
is a way to avoid Democratic
accountability certainly
they'll just use them in a really
arbitrary and capricious way all of that
contained in this silly little ex
exchange about beer because it's not
going to be so silly when the exchange
is about the next vaccine you're gonna
have to take that's not going to be so
silly when the exchange is about how
you're gonna have to shut down your
business and lock down and not go to
Granny's funeral and you're gonna have
to vote by mail because covid 23 has
come around and the election's right
around the corner that's going to be a
little less funny about beer we're all
going to be drinking probably
significantly more when that happens but
it's going to be the exact same
principle at Play
speaking of Joe Biden
the Democrat leader in the house
Hakeem Jeffries has just come out and
he's on the the defense
against the Rumblings that the
Republicans are considering impeaching
Joe Biden
they have nothing to show for their
majority throughout the year and so as a
natural consequence of that they just
continue to take orders from Donald
Trump their Puppet Master in Chief who
has directed them uh to persecute and to
go after uh Joe Biden which may take the
form of an illegitimate impeachment
inquiry
pot meat Kettle yes obviously very
hypocritical insane that as they're
arresting Donald Trump uh after they
impeached Donald Trump twice over
complete nonsense uh they're complaining
that the Republicans are considering
opening an impeachment inquiry into Joe
Biden when did this all start this
started with Watergate when the
Democrats were prepared to impeach
Richard Nixon over nothing and then it
accelerated during the Clinton era when
the Republicans impeached Bill Clinton
over perjury and then
they didn't impeach Bush they didn't
impeach Barack Obama John Boehner said
we're not going to impeach Obama
basically just because he was the first
black president they didn't want to be
called racist and then they didn't they
made up for lost time when they
impeached Trump twice and now the
Republicans might impeach Joe Biden so
this is just what we do now the
political opposition just impeaches the
executive this has become the pattern
it's not the exception the Democrats did
start it with Nixon just as the
Democrats started the Supreme Court
fights with with Robert Bork but the
Republicans have participated too this
is the way the system works now and as
usual the Republicans are behind because
it's no longer just about are we going
to open an impeachment inquiry now the
Democrats have already
up to the ante they are now arresting
the former president
they're now arresting the opposition
leader they're now arresting the lawyers
who have the audacity to to be lawyers
and to represent the sitting president
of the United States they're arresting
political dissidents like the five
pro-lifers who demonstrated against
abortion they're facing 11 years in the
clink they're going to lock up hundreds
of January sisters who committed the
heinous traitorous treasonous crime of
of wandering around the capitol for a
few hours and then going home uh
it's a sad state that our political
order is such that we're always going to
impeach the other guy now or that that's
at least the expectation but the sadder
fact is we're still trailing behind
we're still fighting yesterday's War
where the the Republicans bring a knife
to the fight and the Democrats bring a
bazooka oh we're considering opening an
impeachment inquiry cool they're going
to put Trump in an orange jumpsuit for
700 years if they don't outright execute
them okay so maybe
start engaging in law fair a little bit
more aggressively a little bit more on
par with what the Democrats have already
been doing doesn't look good for us and
when you want to look good you got to
check out gen yourself right now go to
geniusell.com when you look in the
mirror do you see dark spots they're not
going to go away on their own you're not
going to just wish them away you need
help from geniusl's Dark Spot Corrector
the Dark Spot Corrector has not won but
three Cutting Edge ingredients goes to
work fast on sunspots dark spots liver
spots and even old discoloration both on
your face and hands you'll be amazed at
how quickly you'll see results you can
now enjoy what is left of that summer
sun Beach days and barbecues with that
embarrassing spots with genucel you will
see the results or your money back no
questions asked go to geniusell.com
right now geniusell.com Knowles get your
dark spot corrector with the new genius
almost popular package say goodbye to
those pesky spots tomorrow really love
the company love the owner Coptic
Christian who left Egypt for the
American dream they're offering free
shipping free returns best luxury
skincare you've ever used all 70 7-0 off
all orders will include a mystery luxury
gift while supplies last geniusell.com
slash Knowles
my favorite comment
yesterday is from Lindsay Hickman 9604
who says the most bleeps in a daily wire
show ever
and none of them were curses that's true
if you were watching this show on The
Daily wire yesterday maybe go check it
out on YouTube it's kind of fun to see
how few syllables I was able to get in
in my introduction
because I had had the temerity to
speak about reality in a clear way so
you're not allowed to do that on YouTube
and at least in one particular case
anymore so you can you can catch that
and if you were watching on YouTube you
should go watch it on daily wire plus if
you want to figure out what I was
actually saying
now finally finally we've arrived at my
favorite time of the week when I get to
hear from you in the mailbag this
mailbag is sponsored by Pure Talk go to
puretalk.com Knowles for your free super
durable 5G Samsung Galaxy when you
switch to Pure Talk take it away
hi Michael it's Kyle C here first I
wanted to say that I really appreciate
your straightforward and honest
assessment of the state of the GOP race
so far I personally think you do the
best out of any commentators and giving
analysis of the race
so my question is related to it and
specifically about how the Democrats are
clearly interested in bringing back
covered lockdowns and rules back into
society in my opinion one of the biggest
problems for Rhonda sandis's campaign is
that arguably his biggest strength in
comparison to Trump is the handling of
kovid but people have basically
forgotten about it or don't really care
to talk about covid anymore so with this
renewed interest from Democrats bringing
back the covet craziness do you think
the spotlight on this will help the
DeSantis campaign at all enough to
bridge the massive lead that Trump holds
right now or do you think it will have
little to no boost for him I'd really
appreciate your thoughts thank you very
much yes I think this is desantis's best
shot right now the Democrats are testing
out whether or not we have the stomach
for covid Insanity again so they're
doing it one school one company and one
industry okay now maybe it's two schools
and they're they're just testing it to
see if we'll we'll will go along with it
and people probably will
because it was politically very
effective for the Democrats
um so desantis's Best Shot certainly is
to
remind people that he was very strong
during covid I'm not convinced this
whole even that would bring him across
the Finish Line because DeSantis will
continue to govern well on kovid and
Trump will not have any responsibility
he'll just be on the campaign Trail and
he can say whatever he wants and come
out strongly against the covid lockdowns
and it'll sound just as good you know in
the same way that Vivek ramaswamy has
never held public office but he says
things that are very appealing and he's
and he's had a successful career in
private Enterprise so when he says
things he gets just as much credit if
not more credit than Governors or
Senators who have who have been in the
government Arena on those issues that
would be my guess
if
DeSantis can really tie fauci around
Trump's neck it might help pull him down
I do agree it's his best shot I'm not
sure it's enough but it but it's his
best shot keep going
dearest doctor of love at the daily wire
I have two questions for which I need
your Suave wisdom
first and most importantly is it
possible to be a part of the creme de La
Creme without taking on the moniker of
cream puff no my sock-footed loafers are
far too heavy for such a designation
yeah I know you got a dance man
I don't make it early with the woman for
a couple months and despite both being
in our mid to late 20s neither of us
have ever been in a serious or long-term
relationship
I have never known someone with whom
I've met eye to eye with on everything
more than with her everything from
theology to family roles political views
life goals even down to my new details
that are of no real importance
the problem is that neither of us feels
particularly attracted to the other is
this where an Opposites Attract cliche
comes in is attraction something that
grows as you get to know someone beyond
the first couple months
my question is how much of a role do you
see romantic attraction playing in a
relationship
no other woman that I have ever have
been attracted to has ever reciprocated
that affection so do I just give up on
finding that and continue pursuing a
relationship with someone I'm not
particularly attracted to but see life
through the same lens as or does
romantic attraction play an important
role in a relationship thanks for your
help
a really good question
yes it can grow and yes if you marry
this woman you could have a wonderful
beautiful marriage
and the the love it's a good marriage
your level deepen I love sweet little
Elisa today more than I ever have
I and I've Loved sweet little Elisa for
decades but the caveat I'll say there is
and I went to middle school and high
school together I remember this is a
little this might be TMI I remember
having like a dream about sweet little
Elisa when we were in sixth or seventh
grade like I thought she was just a
little haughty you know when we were
when we were 12 or whatever we were and
I I I actually remember the dream and it
was Saucy and not fit for the queen and
I won't mention it but
I was in instantly
physically attracted to uh my beloved
wife and
I think it does it's important I do
think it's I'm not saying you can't have
a good marriage without that people have
in history
but especially you say you've never had
any relationship before you don't really
know how to do it I
you you might just consider your
circumstances I mean how how old are you
how what how large is your Social Circle
uh how long do you want to wait until
you do get married do you want to play
the field a little bit I
you know Sweden Lisa and I split up for
college and you know
I
sometimes wake up in a cold sweat
thinking of how awful my life would be
had I not married sweet little Elise and
that's because of obviously the most
important kind of Attraction which is
the attraction to her virtue and her
like goodness and all those things
um but also you know she's just a hottie
I don't know and and that matters too
we're physical creatures too we're
incarnate we're not just floating in
outer space you know in The Ether or
something like that so I wouldn't
the physical is not primary and it
should not be Primary in any love affair
or certainly in any marriage
but
you got a body you are your body too
as well as your soul okay we got more to
get to we got more voicemail back we got
more written mailbag we've got
of course fake headline Friday I need
your help in Discerning which the fake
headline is so head on over now if you
were just a member of the uh hoi polloi
out there go to dailywire.com use code
Knowles become a member we'll see you
over there
[Music]